Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus erste Sendung im ne
Jahr wo erreiche ich dich wieder mal zu
Hause zu Hause ich setze beherzt und
heiter mein langweiliges Leben fort und
jedes Jahr hat man irgendwie gute
Vorsätze und möchte so ein paar
entscheidende Dinge an seinem Leben
ändern und wenn das Jahr vorbei ist
fällt einem auf dass es eigentlich
ziemlich genauso war wie die Jahre davor
also zumindestens im Hinblick auf die
Vorsätze die man gehabt hat bist du
jemand der der der Vorsätze macht ja und
sich überlegt okay nächstes jah es muss
anders werden ja also nicht unbedingt
jetzt gerade zu Silvester ne aber dass
man sich sich soim im auslaufenden Jahr
also ein schönes Beispiel ist ähm es
gibt einen Freund von mir mit dem der
Macht ganz ganz tolle Weihnachts und
Geburtstagsgrüße und Wünsche und auch
ausführlich und toll und so weiter und
immer wenn ich dann zu meinem Geburtstag
von ihm die bekomme dann fällt mir auf
ich habe dir das ganze Jahr gar nicht
gesehen ja ja und dabei hatte ich mir
doch im letzten Jahr noch vorgenommen ja
wir müssen wirklich unbedingt mal wieder
treffen ja und das fällt einem
eigentlich auf dass es immer die
gleichen Muster sind also bei mir gehört
immer dazu mehr mit Freunden machen
weniger zu arbeiten das nehme ich mir
eigentlich seit Jahren vor und am Ende
stelle ich dann fest dass es eigentlich
von kleinen Ausnahmen abgesehen
vielleicht wieder genauso war wie in den
Jahren vorher also die Gewohnheiten sind
einfach viel stärker als der wile ja das
ist war also das Thema mit mit ich bin
niemand der sich große Vorsätze so macht
habe ich nie gemacht ich habe auch nie
große Pläne so für mein Leben gemacht
weil ich glaube auch so geprägt durch
meine Kindheit irend ich habe immer
gemerkt wie schnell das alles ganz
anders werden kann und alles ganz anders
sein kann und deswegen sind so Vorsätze
und große Pläne waren nie so mein Thema
ich habe einfach immer probiert und
geguckt es ist ja kein großer Plan wenn
man sagt ich muss mir mal ein bisschen
mehr Zeit für viele Dinge nehmen wo ich
mir zu wenig Zeit für genommen habe ne
also ich bin ja auch nicht der Mann der
großen Pläne und denke jetzt W so von
nun an wird mein Leben ganz ganz anders
und machen alles Neue und nichts mehr
das natürlich nicht aber dass man so
Tendenzen erkennt dass man so merkt was
in den Routinen des Lebens zu kurz kommt
ne also man das ist ja ich habe ja schon
so häufig über die Politik gelästert
indem ich gesagt habe wir erleben eine
Diktatur der Taktik über die Strategie
das langfristige geht verloren und am
Ende haben wir nichts anderes als eine
unendliche Aneinanderreihung von
kurzfristigen taktischen Entscheidungen
und die reine Wahrheit ist dass es in
meinem Leben oft ähnliches das also so
die großen Dinge an denen ich denke das
müsste man mehr machen und hier müsste
man endlich mal mehr machen und so
weiter und Sachen die viel mit sozialem
zu tun haben dass sie am Ende dann doch
wieder nicht so gemacht worden sind wie
man sich das vorgenommen hat und nachher
diese ganzen taktischen Routinen dann
doch wieder das Jahr strukturiert haben
mhm es ist warah ja aber das Thema dass
du vorhin angesprochen hast Leute die
einem wichtig sind öfter zu sehen dass
das nehmen ich ich weiß auch nicht ob
das eine Frage der Alters ist ja man man
merkt plötzlich was wirklich wichtig ist
und das sind tatsächlich Freundschaften
das sind natürlich die Kinder und so
weiter aber ne wenn du wenn du dann das
Gespräch so das jahresendgespräch mit
meinem Freund Wolfram z.B ja liebe Grüße
an der Stelle wenn ich mit dem rede dann
merke ich immer ach ist schön und wir
hätten uns eigentlich so viel zu sagen
und dann steht immer da dieses dieser
Wunsch in nächsten Jahr müssen wir das
hinkriegen und dann klappt's wieder
nicht weil er so viel arbeitet weil ich
auch irgendwie viel zu tun habe und so
weiter und es funktioniert nicht aber du
merkst du kannst immer nahtlos am
letzten guten Gespräch ansetzen ja das
das ist das woran man eine gute
Freundschaft genau das ist eine riesige
eine Qualität die dir zeigt okay da ist
jemand da gibt's so ein blindes
Verständnis und und dafür so wenig Zeit
zu haben oder auch mit meinem Freund
Martin z.B ja liebe Grüße nach Südtirol
das gleiche ja wann immer wir uns sehen
und manchmal wirklich monatelang nicht
oder auch hören ähm wir knüpfen nahtlos
an an dem was wir das letzte Mal
gesprochen hatten und es ist eine so
tiefe Vertrautheit da ein sich nicht
erklären müssen ein auch wie soll man
sagen nicht dankbar sein müssen im Sinne
von jetzt tut er mir man gefallen oder
ich tue mir man gefallen da erwartet
keiner Dankbarkeit sondern es ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit mache ich gerne
ja ganz ganz uneigennützig und das ist
etwas was ähm was ja am Ende wichtig ist
und diese Gedanken macht man sich
natürlich schon am Jahresende und ich
habe
äh diesbezüglich äh denke ich gerade so
gegen Jahresende denke ich häufiger mal
nach ich habe das Buch von Axel Hacke
gelesen über die Heiterkeit ist ein
großartiges Buch über die Heiterkeit in
schwierigen Zeiten und die Frage wie
wichtig uns der Ernst des Lebens sein
sollte ja Heiterkeit wichtiges Thema für
dich Richard ja ich finde auch ein Thema
womit er sehr genau aufgespürt hat was
die Leute beschäftigt also wie viele
Leute gibt's die sich sagen wo ist
eigentlich meine Heiterkeit geblieben
dass man so das Gefühl hat in den
letzten Jahren
Ukraine Krieg na ostkonflikt dass die
Dinge so so nahen einen rankommen und
dass man Gelassenheit verloren hat oder
es einem schwerer fällt heiter und
unbekümmert zu sein und es ist ja wir
haben im Podcast häufiger drüber
gesprochen und ich werde das bei
Vorträgen ganz häufig gefragt woher
nehmen sie ihren Optimismus oder haben
sie noch Zuversicht oder glauben Sie
dass man berechtigterweise die Hoffnung
haben kann dass die Weltlage besser wird
und so weiter also was was viele
Menschen beschäftigt und die auch dieses
Gefühl dass so dass so der der Ernst des
Lebens so fast bis zur
Bitterkeit gerade durch die
weltkonstellation und durch Kriege und
Katastrophen und so dass man sich davon
gar nicht so richtig erholt und dass man
die seine Heiterkeit verliert ich glaube
das trifft ziemlich gut die Stimmung in
unserem Land und das kann man sagen
hängt natürlich auch ne die kastev
Antwort damit zusammen dass wir eine
ziemlich überaltete gellschaft sind die
sind dann meistens nicht ganz so heiter
andererseits könnte man sich wieder
sagen wo ist die Gelassenheit des Alters
geblieben ja es gibt ja auch Alters
Heiterkeit so dieses so froh sein was
man alles schon tolles oder nicht so
tolles geschafft hat oder hinter sich
gebracht hat oder so also es ist ja
nicht notwendig dass man mit dem Alter
dann irgendwie
vergriesgramt ja aber ich glaube
heiterkeit ist ein in der Tat großes
wichtiges Thema ja also Axel Hacke liebe
Grüße an der Stelle übrigens ein toller
Schreiber ne Axel hackig ich lese den
regelmäßig war auch glaub ich ein oder
zweimal bei uns in der Sendung und
schreibt immer so kleine Büchlein und
der beschreibt so schön diesen Prozess
ja also er kriegt diesen Auftrag über
diesen Begriff zu schreiben über
Heiterkeit und merkt dann plötzlich das
ist ein wirklich großes Thema und und er
sagt die Heiterkeit von der ich rede ist
was dauerhafteres es handelt sich um
eine grundsätzliche Sichtweise auf die
Welt ja auf uns selbst und auf andere
auf das Leben und den Tod und es geht
nicht um Verdrängung der Bedrohungen
denen wir uns gegenüber sehen sondern um
die Frage wie wir mit ihnen umgehen ob
tiefer Ernst die einzig mögliche
Sichtweise ist und das ist eine sehr
gute Frage ja also ich ich glaube wir
sind von diesem tiefen Ernst enorm
erfüllt vielleicht auch ein bisschen
kulturell bedingt sind die Deutschen ja
hochbegabt für tiefen ernst für Tiefsinn
und Grübeleien die irgendwo in im
Dunklen Sümpfen versinken
in der Angel sechischen Welt ist das z.B
anders wenn man mal wirklich hingehen
würde würde gucken wie viel Humor steckt
in den Büchern der großen
angelsächischen Philosophen und wie viel
Humor in den Büchern der deutschen dann
würde man in der Tat einen ziemlich
großen Unterschied sehen
mm und ich meine für für die angelschs
sch für für die Engländer ist ja ist ja
ganz harte ernste Themen des Lebens mit
Heiterkeit zu betrachten ja eigentlich
sogar regelrecht das der schwarze Humor
oder wie Humor definiert ist also immer
so Humor im Angesicht des Abgrundes und
das ist tatsächlich eine Eigenschaft da
sind die Deutschen überhaupt nicht begab
für also das schwere leicht zu neben und
zwar nicht leicht zu neben im Sinne von
leichtsinnig damit umgehen oder
leichtfüßig zu sein ne gibt's im
deutschen lauter Bruder Leichtfuß lauter
abwertende Begriffe für ja sondern zu
meinen dass man dass man ich
meine man man stirbt irgendwann man wird
älter man wird auch im Laufe seines
Lebens nicht zwingend schöner war von
manchen abgesehen vielleicht aber bei
den allermeisten jedenfalls nicht und
man wird mit einer gewissen
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch kränker und so
und das kann man sich alles angucken da
kann man sich ganze Zeit darüber
beklagen bis man tot ist oder man kann
sich eben sagen wie schön ist doch dass
ich an dieser Veranstaltung namens Leben
teilnehmen durfte und wenn man es
schafft mal so
gelegentlich Betrachter seiner selbst zu
sein aus dieser Distanz heraus sich
nicht mehr so wichtig zu nehmen mhm ja
dann gelingt es einem eben auch auf eine
auf eine schöne heitere Art ja nicht
nicht sich nicht sich nicht selbst
auszulachen aber zumindestens ein
bisschen über sich zu
schmunzeln du hast gerade was total
schönes gesagt du sagst aus der Distanz
heraus und das alles nicht so wichtig zu
nehmen Axel Hacke ich war so gespannt
darauf wie er sich sozusagen diesem
Begriff nähert und wenn du mal reinhorst
in Dich wir wir beide so eine
Generation je jeder hat da natürlich
seine eigenen Synapsen und Verbindungen
aber wenn ich zurückdenke und
interessanterweise hat er genau dieses
Beispiel genommen wenn du sagen würdest
prototypisch was ist heiter z.B im
Fernsehen was war eine heitere schöne
Sendung hätte ich zwei im Kopf gehabt
die eine war D Dali und die andere war
was bin ich Robert Lemke und genau das
beschreibt er ist doch glaube ich im
Untertitel sogar heiteres berufer ja
genau und und und der sagt eben das das
Lachen das lustige das gehört so zum
heiteren dieses Abends ja also die die
Idee war ja also Menschen kommen rein
und die Zuschauer erfahren dann was die
beruflich machen und dieses Rateteam das
da sitzt ja ich glaube wir müssen einmal
kurz erklären was was bin ich eigentlich
war die und die dieses Rateteam muss
sozusagen nur durch Fragen
herausfinden was machen diese Leute
beruflich so immer wenn der ja sag
simples
Konzept und immer wenn er ja sagt D mal
weiterraten und wenn er nein sagt dann
muss jemand anders raten und es werden 5
Mark in ein porzellanschwein
reingeklimpert richtig richtig genau und
Robert Lemke der dann immer die Frage
stellt dir welches schweindall hätten es
denn gerne genau so und äh und dann und
dann stellst Du i eine Frage und sagst
also hat ihr Beruf was mit Logistik zu
tun ja und wenn man sie jetzt morgen da
rausnehmen würde aus dem was sie da tun
würden wir da noch unsere Pakete kriegen
nein so und dann bist du raus ja dann
kommt der nächste das heißt und er sagt
die zentrale Botschaft dieser Sendung
war eigentlich das ist hier alles nicht
so wichtig das ist ein kleines
entspanntes Spiel das ist keine große
Show da wird niemand mit großem Getöse
vorgestellt da ist es nie laut in einer
entspannten Runde in diesem
unspektakulär eingerichteten Studio ja
da gab's den den foxterriia Struppi von
von Lemke der hat das Geld bewacht ne
wenn du dich erinnerst dann hab ich
überhaupt nichtr doch der STR ist dann
irwann gestorben und dann gab's Jackie
den Nachfolger Hund der dann das Geld
bewacht hat und auch das war so schön
weil ne also ein Foxterrier ist nicht
ernst zuun neehmen als Wachhund und es
geht aber auch eben nicht um Millionen
es ging maximal um 10 f Markstücke ja es
ging um ganz normale Menschen aber ihre
durchaus interessante Arbeit niemand
will wirklich was das Publikum soll
nicht brüllend lachen so beschreibt das
Axel und ist so schön und und die
ratenden müssen auch nicht unbedingt
erfolgreich sein sondern im Gegenteil
wenn sie es nicht sind wenn sie es nicht
heraus viel schöner ja ganz genau also
das ist die Zeit der unschuldigen
Mattscheiben Späßchen ja genau genau ja
also als das Fernseher noch Mattscheibe
hieß und man über das
mattscheibenspäßchen lachte das war
natürlich sehr ambivalent ne weil diese
diese deutsche Fernsehunterhaltung
tunlst alles vermiet was diese diese
fast kindliche Heiterkeit
beeintträchtigen konntehm ich habe ja
mal so sehr beeindruckende Dokumentation
gesehen über mehr mehrere deutsche
Talkmaster und was die so vorher erlebt
hatten bevor sie Talkmaster im deutschen
Fernsehen waren also die bekannte und
und und und und wirklich anrührende
Geschichte von Hans Rosental der ja dann
so zum Inbegriff des Frohsinns im
deutschen Fernsehen war gen h ja und der
den der den Holocaust in einer Berliner
Gartenlaube versteckt aber nur so um
Haaresbreite überlebt hat und davon
gekommen ist oder kuhlenkampf der in
einer speziellen Einheit im im Dritten
Reich
im im im Zweiten Weltkrieg in Russland
war eine Einheit von der fast alle
anderen gestorben sind er gehörte zu den
ganz wenigen Überlebenden und hatte
glaube ich auch abgefrorene Zehen und so
weiter und machtte dann so gelegentlich
so kleine Späßchen Witzchen so über über
seine Füße und seine Schuhe und wie auch
immer also man muss sozusagen diese
Heiterkeit ja vor dem Hintergrund des
Grauens eigentlich sehen mm genau ne
also dass die Deutschen haben die die
Stunde Null erfunden ne so hieß das ja
die Gründung der Bundesrepublik und
diese Stunde Null bedeutete ja nicht nur
man hat jetzt ein Grundgesetz und eine
parlamentarische Demokratie wieder und
so weiter sondern das hiß W für ganz
ganz viele auch dass man über das was
vorher war nicht mehr geredet hat mhm
genau und dass man eine sehensucht hatte
ja also irgendwo
zwischen langen Arbeitszeiten fettigen
Schweinebraten und Kriegsgräber
fürürsorge ja über Heinz ehhard Witze zu
lachen Axel Hacke schreibt auch über
über diese Dinge und der zitiert unter
anderem ist deswegen lässt sich da gut
anschließen das was du gerade sagtest
Richard diese Erfahrungen der Kindheit
und
Jugend er zitiert Jean-Jacques semp
Zeichner wo wo er sagte die Menschen
wirken immer so ganz klein und so
verloren in so riesigen Landschaften und
so weiter und der hatte eine sehr sehr
harte Kindheit sehr harte Kindheit und
sagt Maline Kindheit war wirklich alles
andere als lustig und das ist schöner
Satz gewiss der Grund dafür dass ich das
heitere so sehr liebe ja fin ich
interessant ja ja und wenn ich jetzt mal
so denke meine Begegnungen z.B mit auch
mit Holokaust Überlebenden wenn ich an S
perell denke der leider verstorben ist
der die Vorlage war sozusagen oder
dessen Lebensgeschichte für Hitlerjunge
Salomon mit dem ich bis zum
Schluss so ein bisschen befreundet war
und ich habe ab und zu mal besucht in
Tel Aviv mochte den wahnsinnig gerne das
war auch so einer der hatte jeden ichen
Wahnsinn erlebt und in wirklich so viele
Abgründe
geblickt und bis zum Schluss ja das war
das alles beherrschende Thema ja und ich
habe das ja mal erzählt wie ich mit ihm
das war das Eindrücklichste Erlebnis mit
ihm auf dem Friedhof in lot stand und
schneit wie wahnsinnig es war Januar es
war unvorstellbar kalt damals in Polen
und dann stand er am Grab seines VATS
und hat geweint und spricht dann
plötzlich jedisch mit ihm und ich habe
ih dann hinterher gef fragt s was was
was ist passiert und er sagte weißt du
ich habe mich bei meinem Papa dafür
entschuldigt äh dass es mir früher als
Kind den Peine die haben mal in Peine
gelebt bevor sie vertrieben worden sind
oder geflüchtet sind äh dass es mir
peinlich war wenn er so jidisch
gesprochen hat und dann so hielter
weltlerisch war und da habe ich mich
geschämt für meine Eltern und dafür habe
ich mich entschuldigt wir reden von
einem Mann der damals schon mindestens
85 Jahre alt war aber dieses heitere auf
der anderen Seite dieses gelassene das
hatte der auch das war jemand der war
auf eine Art und Weise unerschütterlich
und Heiterkeit ist ja sehr viel mehr ne
das ähm als einfach so eine so eine so
eine bloße
Fröhlichkeit Wilhelm Schmied hat das mal
so schön beschrieben der sagt es ist
eine phänomenale Erfahrung dass
Heiterkeit sich gerade in der
Konfrontation mit der Abgründigkeit der
Existenz einstellt ne also gerade dann
wenn das Leben besonders schwer wird
dann ist die Heiterkeit sozusagen als
Erleichterung zu entdecken die sich d
ja genau die sich dadurch auszeichnet
die zugrunde liegende Tragik nicht zu
leugnen das ist natürlich wahnsinnig
schöner Gedanke und ist auch eine Form
von wie soll man sagen innerer Freiheit
würde ich sagen die gar nicht so leicht
zu gewinnen ist weil ich glaube es ist
natürlich zur Heiterkeit auch dazu
gehört auf eine sehr unverkramppfte Art
und Weise über sich selbst nachzudenken
und vielleicht auch nicht zu viel und da
wir heute in den sozialen Netzwerken
unausgesetzt dabei sind Bilder von uns
zu produzieren und uns in spiegeln zu
spiegeln die uns unbekannte Leute
vorhalten das ist quasi das
absolute Gegenteil von Heiterkeit weil
wenn man auch nur in in paar hundert
Spiegel geguckt hat von dem Blicken
anderer Leute die man nicht kennt die
man nicht weiß warum und so weiter die
man aber deren Urteile man zugespiegelt
bekommt dann wird man entweder wenn sie
positiv sind abhängig von dem Applaus
den man bekommt und wenn sie negativ
sind süchtig danach und wenn W sie
negativ sind verliert man seine
grundheiterkeit und das unschuldige
Verhältnis zu sich selbst von dem man
sich immer eine Prise erhalten muss um
gut gelaunt aufzuwachen mhm und ich
denke dass die sozialen Netzwerke sehr
viel dazu beitragen dass wir
unausgesetzt damit beschäftigt sind
darüber nachzudenken wie andere uns
sehen und ich glaube dass das so eine
Geisteshaltung ist die niemals in
Heiterkeit führen kann so und die führt
dann wirklich dazu dass man mit der Nase
in jedem Quark versinkt mhm ist
interessant also könnte einer der Gründe
sein neben der deutschen Mentalität
warum wir uns im Augenblick mit der
Heiterkeit so schwer tun du musst ja nur
an Twitter denken ja Twitter ich meine
Menschen die einen großen Teil ihres
Lebens auf Twitter verbringen
verbringen ein großen Teil ihres Lebens
nicht mit anderen Dingen ja das führt
schon dazu dass eine spezielle Klientel
das überhaupt in diesem Ausmaß macht und
dann kann man feststellen dass der
Grundton auf Twitter ja das Gegenteil
von heiterkeit ist man gib begibt sich
also in eine Welt des nightids der
Missgunst des überproportionalen
austeilens das übereinander herfallens
des klugscheißens des verbesserns des
korrigierens und und und und undm und
ich meine wenn man dann eine gewisse
sucht entwickelt hat und das täglich
oder wöchentlich und so weiter macht wie
will man da zu einer heiteren
Gelassenheit Gemütsruhe oder irgendwas
überhaupt wieder finden also wir
verlieren uns in der Vielzahl der
Spiegel das ist das was ich sagen will
ja das ist interessant deswegen musste
ich gerade lachen weil ich weiß oder
vermute Du hast das Buch von Axel Hacke
noch nicht gelesen nee genau und genau
das ist aber die Spur auf auf der er
auch unterwegs ist genau das und und er
nennt auch ein paar sehr interessante
Beispiele dafür und sagt wir wir haben
so
diese ja wie soll man
sagen er nennt das Beispiel Armin
Laschet ja das das Lachen wenn du dich
erinnerst das Lachen im AT ja das Lachen
im AT so und das Interessante ist es
geht ja bei diesem Lachen ging es nicht
um große Politik es ging nicht um die
Frage ob Armin laschit ein guter
Politiker oder ein schlechter Politiker
ist das machst du nicht daran
fest aber die Reaktion die
gnadenlosichkeit der Reaktion dass
dieses vernichtende das war wirklich
unvorstellbar und Axel Hacke hat
schreibt das was was ich damals
irgendwann auch mal in der Sendung
gesagt habe gab's richtig Ärger ich
sagte ist das nicht auch so lösender
Moment wenn es gerade besonders tragisch
ist er schreibt auf auch auf
Beerdigungen auf denen gelacht wird dass
sind nicht die schlechtesten
Beerdigungen das sind eigentlich eher
sogar die die die besseren ja weil es
diesen Moment der Erlösung braucht aber
diesen Moment der Erlösung gibt es
irgendwie nicht mehr und und da glaube
ich schon dass das heiter uns ein
bisschen ab handanten gekommen ist ich
habe übrigens in dem Buch das erste Mal
und das fand ich sehr interessant wurde
immer ein großes Geheimnis darum gemacht
und eigentlich interessiert auch gar
kein mehr warum Armin Lasche da gelacht
hat also
angeblich war es so er steht relativ
weit weg vom Bundespräsidenten das heißt
er kann ihn nicht wirklich hören ja die
kriegen also auch nicht wirklich mit was
da vorne geredet wird ja es war eine
kurze sehr dramatische Rede die
frankwalter steinmeiler gehalten hat
aber laschett steht mit seinen Leuten
mit seiner Entourage relativ weit
abseits kann ih nicht hören und hat
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich
mitgekriegt dass er ein Visier von
Fotografen war so und da hat er
angeblich dem örtlichen Landrat im Spaß
vorgeworfen dass dieser also der der
Landrat den Bundespräsidenten mit Herr
Steinmeier begrüßt hätte und nicht als
Herr
bundespräsidentm und daraufhin hat
angeblich der Landrat gesagt er sei halt
überrascht gewesen dass der auch so
klein sei wie er also wie Armin lched ja
und darauf hat lched herzlich gelacht
und übrigens nicht als
einüicht der
Punkt ja genau äh und und es gibt noch
weitere Beispiele ja wenn du mal
überlegst z.B das Absurde
entschuldigungstheater dass die die
Berliner Grünen Spitzenkandidatin
Bettina jaresch ich weiß nicht ob du das
mitgekriegt hast die hat damals auf
einer landesdelegierten Konferenz
spontan auf die Frage was sie als Kind
gerne geworden wäre gesagt
indianerhäbltling ja danach war die
Karriere fast beendet ja mein Gott ja
aber aber das war das ist die die
öffentliche Humorlosigkeit ja und
sozusagen der der Puritanismus genau in
allen ethischen und ethnischen Fragen
sorgt natürlich dafür dass das mit der
Heiterkeit nicht mehr so einfach ist
weil eine Voraussetzung für Heiterkeit
die Unbekümmertheit ja nicht mehr
möglich ist man sehr sehr wachsam sein
muss richtig ja aber die die die
Geschichte mit DIN Lasche die die muss
ich ehrlich sagen die die ging mir nah
weil ich dachte Mann wieso sagt man das
denn da nicht einfach mal erklärt das
doch einfach warum er da gelacht hat das
hätte doch jeder verstanden war doch ein
guter Scherz von dem Landrat und wie du
sagst selbstironisch doch wunderbar aber
irgendwie wahrscheinlich will man das da
nicht öffentlich machen weil wir den
Landrat nicht in die Pfanne hauen ja
bist hast du plötzlich ganz viele Zwänge
der hat sich auch gedacht ich macht das
Thema jetzt nicht noch größer als es
ohnehin schon ist indem ich jetzt
anfange in aller Ausführlichkeit die
Situation zu analysieren und damit der
Presse noch zusätzlich wieder irgendwas
hinzuwerfen wo man sich draufszen kann
ja es ist hart ja es ist es ist tragisch
wenn man wegen einem Lachen
diskreditiert wird ja weil es weil es
nichts über deine Lebensleistung aussagt
ne das ist der entscheidende Punkt ja
gut man hat vorgeworfen hat gesagt in so
einer Situation ja wo es ja um was
katastrophales ging all die Menschen die
da ihre Häuser verloren hatten und was
weiß ich was da gibt's nichts zu lachen
also ähnlich wie bei der Beerdigung wo
man nicht lacht so und hat dann daraus
geschlossen dass er nicht die Reife für
einen Staatsmann hat wenn er das nicht
schafft auf in dieser Situation nicht zu
lachen so und das ist natürlich jetzt
sehr päpstlicher Maßstab der da angelegt
ist ein sehr päpslicher Maßstab und und
da kommen wir jetzt an einen total
interessanten Punkt Richard Axel Hacke
spürt dem auch nach und sagt
m im Grunde hat das was mit dem
Christentum zu tun und eigentlich hat es
was mit griechischer Philosophie zu tun
und eigentlich hat es zu tun mit
Aristoteles und Platon ja also
Aristoteles der sozusagen eher die
Auffassung vertritt Lachen ist genuin
menschlich ist ist etwas von Tieren
genauau werden Platon sozusagen das
Lachen verurteilt und und sagt das
gehört zum niedersten was der Mensch zu
bieten hat also quasi
sagt Platon ist sozusagen der Urvater
aller humorlosen dieses Planeten W te
nee teile ich nicht ich weiß das eine
verbreitete Meinung ja also es gibt
nicht allzu viele Stellen wo Platon sich
zu dem Thema äußert mhm und zitiert
werden normalerweise immer dieselben
beiden das eine ist aus der politea wo
er den Wächtern also den zukünftigen
Regenten eines äh erfundenen
Idealstaat sagt die sollten nicht lachen
also nach dem Motto die die dürfen sich
nicht leppisch äh auf aufführen ja die
dürfen keinen laschätschen Fehler machen
ja die müssen also immer würdevoll und
ernst und so weiter sein das ist die
eine Stelle und die die andere Stelle da
bezieht er sich darauf dass er sagt man
soll andere Leute nicht auslachen weil
das auslachen letztlich mehr über den
eigenen schlechten Charakter sagt und
dem nightid quasi freie Wahn verschafft
das sind diese beiden Sachen und daraus
jetzt zu schließen dass Platon humorlos
war und auch noch auf die Idee zu kommen
etwa im Gegenteil zu Sokrates der ja
immer witzig ironisch und was weiß ich
was war also
99,9% dessen was wir von Sokrates wissen
oder für Sokrates halten stammt aus der
Feder Platons ja ja das heißt also
diesen
listig mit mit Witz gesegneten Sokrates
den hat Platon in dieser Form überhaupt
erst erfunden und ihm also in vielen
seiner Dialogen da zur Zentralfigur
gemacht deswegen wä ich mal ganz
vorsichtig da und auch dieses Gerücht da
in der Akademie da hätten die Leute
nicht lachen dürfen die Spenden und
sowas alles und so also da ist sich ja
auch eine ganz schöne Portion kportage
dahinter wahrscheinlich wir waren nicht
dabei wir waren nicht dabei und ich
glaube ich glaube ich glaube wenn man
wenn man wenn Platon heute wieder
lebendig werden würde wir würden uns
vielleicht doch ein wenig darüber
wundern was für ein Klischee wir da
ausgebitet haben möglicherweise aber ich
ich glaube wo wo Axel Hacke definitiv
recht hat ist dass sozusagen von da
quasi eine direkte Linie ins Christentum
ja das stimmt das stimmt im Christentum
ist es ja tatsächlich ebeno gewesen ich
mE muss ich ja vorstellen also Jesus ist
ja für die also als Christus für die
Menschen am Kreuz gestorben m eben und
die das ist ja das ist ja eine eine
traurige eine erschröckliche Geschichte
ja und
jegliche Form von Witzchen machen
Albernheiten und sowas alles und mit dem
wurde ja der Humor gleich gesetzt wir
haben ja wir reden jetzt nicht über
einen Humor über den wir am Anfang jetzt
hier geredet haben weiß also so Distanz
und Heiterkeit im Angesicht von Tod und
Endlichkeit und katastrophenondern wir
reden ja sozusagen über die leppische
Geisteshaltung ja gegen die Platon sich
da in der politea ausspricht und die war
auch im Christentum äußerst verpönt ja
also Witzchen machen war jetzt nicht das
was man von von Mönchen im Kloster
erwartete oder was was Klerikern Anstand
ja das der Punkt und und diese diese
diese Freudlosigkeit also der Verlust
sozusagen des des des des heiteren
äh dass man den auch benutzt hat um um
Leute sozusagen auch zu beherrschen in
Macht auszuüben in den Griff zu kriegen
das ist unbestritten so also wenn ich ne
wenn ich auch so an meine eigene
Kindheit zum Teil zurückdenke und wenn
du mal die überlegst Umberto eeko hier
der Name der Rose meine genau darum
geht's dort in diesem Roman ne ja ja da
geht's da geht's um die der das Buch
über das komische von Aristoteles also
das Komik die die verlor
genau ein verschollenes Buch my er was
er da in die in die Bibliothek da
versetzt hat genau genau und von von dem
also der der
zuständige kirchenobere da oder
klosterobere nicht will dass die
Menschen die die anderen das Lesen und
deswegen die Seiten vergiftet hat genau
wenn man sie anfasst ne dann und und
dann beim Umblättern auch dann den
Finger
befuchet genau und es gibt da die schöne
Frage William stellt dir da was ist so
beunruhigend daran wenn Menschen lachen
und dann ruft dieser blinde böse Mönch
Lachen tötet die Furcht das ist
interessant und ohne Furcht kann es
keinen Glauben geben weil wer keine
Furcht mehr vor dem Teufel hat der
braucht keinen Gott mehr ja das heißt ne
mit mit also eigentlich dreht sich
dieser ganze Roman um diese Frage und da
geht's auch wieder um Heiterkeit
Mittelalter soll und darf der Mensch
lachen oder nicht ist total interessant
und L Ludwig I französischer König der
glaube ich sehr sehr freundlich und
witzig war der hat das das Problem
gelöst indem er am Freitag nicht gelacht
hat also quasi lachfasten gemacht
hat das heißt das war ein riesen Thema
aus heutiger Perspektive völlig albern
sich die Frage zu stellen darf man
lachen oder darf man nicht aber es war
offenbar etwas was uns kulturell mal
sehr sehr beschäftigt hat ja das stimmt
das stimmt also man man kann jetzt nicht
sagen dass die Geschichte der
abendländische Kultur eine Geschichte
gewesen wäre in der das Lachen so einen
wahnsinnig prädestinierten Wert gehabt
hat oder es allzu viele gegeben hat ich
meine die hat es gegeben aber es ist
nicht die Hauptströmung gewesen ja oder
auch ich meine es gab natürlich auch
Humor und wie ich vorhin ja schon sagte
in der in der Philosophie gerade in der
angelsächsischen Philosophie ein
bisschen auch in der italienischen aber
da immer noch gibt's so diese
Vorstellung dass jemand der Weise ist ja
dass dass der dass der keinen ke keine
Witze macht oder dass wir bringen eent
im deutschen das nicht zusammen weil wir
kriegen Tiefsinn und Humor nicht
zusammen was eben im angelschsison so
eine großartige Kombination miteinander
eingeht und bei uns sind das
einander wieder streitende Dinge mhm das
das Interessante ist diese
Katastrophenstimmung ne die uns ja
gerade so viel beschäftigt und selbst
wenn du ältere Menschen wie Gerhard Baum
z.B er ist über 90 der sitzt dann da und
und sagt dir ganz ehrlich ich ich habe
am Hand meiner Mutter das brennende
Dresden verlassen ja das ist Teil seiner
Geschichte und trotzdem sagt er dir so
schlimm wie Moment war es noch nie und
interessant ist wenn du wenn du z.B aber
was meinte die Stimmung oder die
Weltlage das man kann ja nur die
Stimmung meinen das frage ich mich auch
immer ich lese dir jetzt mal ein Satz
vor Richard wir leben gegenwärtig in
einer Zeit die von Katastrophenstimmung
und Zukunftsängsten erfüllt ist
angesichts sterbender Wälder steigender
Arbeitslosen Z und ganzer Legionen von
Atomraketen scheint der gegenwartsmensch
tatsächlich nichts mehr zu lachen zu
haben es stammt dasus einem Buch aus dem
Jahre
1985 mhm oder noch ein Satz pass auf ist
dies eine Zeit in der die Heiterkeit am
Platz ist das würden wohl die meisten
Menschen verneinen zu viele schlimme
Nachrichten stürmen auf uns ein und bei
manchen gibt es Gründe der Verzweiflung
näher zu sein als der
ist ein Satz von Wilhelm Schmied der
Philosoph über den wir ab und mal reden
und stammt vom Mai 2001 das heißt also
noch
vor diese Sätze kann man immer schreiben
immer schreiben also mit der
Arbeitslosigkeit ist im Augen jetzt
nicht gerade unser hauppr des Moment g
aber ich meine dass man sagt schlimme
Nachrichten und irgendwo sind Kriege und
Katastrophen und was weiß ich was das
konnte man eigentlich schon immer
schreiben seit es Menschen gibt oder
menschliche Kultur oder Zivilisation
gibt ja und der der interessante Punkt
ist und das wird man auch in 20 Jahren
noch machen so Bücher so anfangen ja
aber es zeigt sozusagen diese dieses
Gefühl so schlimm wie Moment war es noch
nie das gibt schon ganz lange ja ich
glaube das ist wie gesagt so alt wie die
Menschheit das ist ja genauso wie diese
Sehnsucht nach einer guten alten Zeit
die es nicht gab mhm ne weil das eben
die Zeit war in der die Leute auch schon
Sehnsucht nach der guten alten Zeit
hatten mhm ja aber ja und das war jene
Zeit in der die Leute ebenfalls
sehensucht nach der guten alten Zeit hat
genau also die gute alte Zeit ist eine
Erfindung des
altersgedächtnisses das ist nichts was
irgendwie real ist ne früher waren die
Dinge eben anders schlecht als sie heute
schlecht sind und die schönen Dinge
waren anders schön als sie heute schön
sind Axel Hacke schreibt denen schönen
Satz der sich anschließende Gedanke ist
gab es so betrachttet überhaupt je eine
Zeit in der Heiterkeit am Platze war
waren die Jahre nicht immer viel zu übel
ja das ist natürlich ein total guter
Punkt also können wir angesichts dessen
was gerade rund um uns herum passiert
heiter sein und die Antwort ist wenn du
das so mitkriegst eindeutig ja und
gerade deshalb sollten wir versuchen
heiter zu sein gibt eine schöne
Geschichte Wiener Autorin Doris Knecht
tolle Autorin kriegt einen Preis und
erzählt bei der Gelegenheit dass ich
eine Leserin im Jahre
2022 bei ihr beschwert hätte weil Knecht
des wagt habe über sowas triviales
Banales wie über ihr Lieblingsessen zu
schreiben und diese Leserin die selber
offenbar den flüchtlingshintergrund hat
sagt das ist lächerlich und es ist
oberflächlich und es ist angesichts
dieser aktuellen Situation Stichwort
Krieg in der Ukraine und so weiter
wirklich peinlich über essensvorlieben
zu schreiben und zu lesen und die
Autorin
Knecht schreibt Doris Knecht schreibt
ihr zurück natürlich haben sie recht
aber ich finde sie haben auch ein
bisschen nicht recht und sagt dann wir
haben diesen Krieg nicht angefangen
keiner von uns wollte diesen Krieg und
alle sind entsetzt ich finde aber nicht
dass wir uns alle Tag und Nacht dafür
schuldig fühlen müssen dass wir weiter
das tun was auch die Menschen in der
Ukraine getan haben und weiter tun
wollen nämlich ganz normal in Frieden zu
leben und sie sagt dann weiter dieser
Krieg das gilt ja genauso auch für Gaza
z.B der wird nicht aufhören äh wenn wir
uns äh aufhören zu freuen an unseren
Kindern an gutem Essen an schöner Kunst
und so weiter das ist natürlich ein
ehrlich gesagt total guter Gedanke weil
dieser Moralismus der der kommt uns ja
auch häufig entgegen also ich erlebe das
häufig in der Sendung wenn man wenn es
dann mal ein bisschen heiterer wird dann
ist gleich wie kann man denn angesichts
dieser Weltlage wie kann man denn dann
sich erlauben
zu lachen und auch mal heiter klingt wie
das christliche Erbe aus dem Mittelalter
ne also dass man denkt was ist denn was
wäre denn das Gegenteil einer heiter
Haltung ja eine verbitterte Haltung
richtig ja also eine kreuznüchterne bis
hin zu verbitterten Haltung und wem und
was einem selber oder anderen ist mit
einer solchen Haltung gedientm und was
in der Welt ist dadurch besser geworden
dass Menschen eine verbitterte Haltung
einnehmen mhm ja das ist schon alles
richtig interessant ist ja finde ich
sozusagen die Geschichte dieser wie soll
man sagen eigentlich ist es ja eine fast
eine panikfantasie ne die sich über
Jahrtausende wenn du so willst
weitergetragen hat und interessant ist
wenn man das historisch betrachtet es
gibt sozusagen in vielen Religionen
Vorstellung von einer
Endzeit wenn man so will aber es gibt
nicht diese Vorstellung einer komplett
Vernichtung ja die die war sozusagen die
panikfantasie des des Christentums ja
die Apokalypse und so weiter ja
merkwürdige waren ja die bei den
Stoikern ne die heute so so so
wog sind ist ja quasi die philosophische
Richtung die am meisten wog ist weil die
Leute hoffen wenn Sie das lesen dass sie
Gelassenheit lernen Boris Becker auch
Stoiker ja nein der der der der kam aus
dem Knast und hat hat erzählt der hat
die die die Stoiker für sich entdeckt ja
ja kann man mal sehen ja und da ist er
wahrscheinlich auch eben gelassen raus
geworden und die Wahrheit ist der Grund
warum die Stoiker so gelassen waren war
nicht weil sie irgendwelche
psychotechniken beherrschen wie man
heiter ist sondern weil sie WUs das
ganze geht sowieso den Bach rter
Historiker hatten nämlich die
Vorstellung dass in einem
tausendjährigen oder 2ita000jährigen
Zyklus die Welt vernichtet wird und
wieder neu entsteht also geht ins Feuer
auf alles alles alles alles verschwindet
und dann beginnt sie genau wieder da wo
sie beim letzten Mal aufgehört hat mhm
das heißt also das menschliche Dasein
ist einem Zyklus einbehalten der die
ewige Wiederkehr des sinnlosen gleichen
ist
also etwas was man nur mit Heiterkeit
und Gelassenheit ertragen kann oder
Suizid begeht aber selbst Suizid begehen
was die hisoiker durchaus als
realistische Optionen für ihr Leben
gesehen haben ändert ja nichts daran an
der Fatalität des weltenlaufes mhm und
da bleibt einem eigentlich wenn man es
durchdenkt außer Gelassenheit nichts
mehr übrig das heißt also die stoische
gelassenheit ist Gelassenheit im
Angesicht der Katastrophe mhm und nicht
das hoffen darauf dass es besser wird
sondern sagen es wird sowieso nicht
besser ja aber warum soll ich mich
darüber aufregen wenn ich doch einmal
erkannt habe dass es nicht besser wird
und wenn ich durch mein Zutun auch nicht
dafür sorgen kann dass es besser wird
ist so der Teil der bei der Historiker
Renaissance meistens so ein bisschen
unterschlagen
wird ja das ist weil das wollen wir
nicht alle ja dass wir Gelassenheit
dadurch gewinnen dass wir daran glauben
dass sowieso alles im Bach untergeht ja
ist richtig also so eine fatalistische
Gelassenheit genau das ist ja Friedrich
Nietsche ne seines Todes ist man gewiss
warum sollte man also nicht heiter sein
mhm wobei er alles andere als ein
heiterer Charakter war die Einsicht die
Einsicht auf der einen Seite aber auf
der anderen Seite war er auch jemand der
extrem kolerisch und sich pausenlos
aufregte und sich in in große Rollen
hinein fantasierte wenn er schrieb und
ein riesiges anerkennungsproblem hatte
und so weiter ja also er war ein sehr
begabter Schriftsteller mm und jeden
Zweifel ein sehr guter Literat und so
weiter aber er war alles andere als ein
gelassener Mensch ja ist ist ist ja auch
schwer ne ich finde ja also Heiterkeit
und Gelassenheit sind ja zwei Dinge die
eigentlich auch zusamm gehören ne ja ich
finde die sind gar nicht so einfach zu
trennen also unheitere unheitere
Gelassenheit die muss ich mich jetzt
gerade mal meinem Kopf ausmalen ja also
das ist ja dann Gleichgültigkeit oder
unterscheidet sich das nicht
dadurchpr der Unterschied ist doch wenn
Gelassenheit mit Gleichgültigkeit
einhergeht dann ist sie keine heiterkeit
ist richtig ne ist richtig also in
Gelassenheit nach dem mot ist mir
sowieso alles egal ist nicht
Heiterkeit sondern nach dem Motor ist
mir sowieso alles egal und deswegen
macht es mir Spaß das ist Heiterkeit
oder also da mischt sich ja noch
irgendwas rein so eine Qualität die so
nicht in jeder Gelassenheit drin ist ja
ist richtig ist ich meine heiter ist auf
auf die Frage sozusagen welches
schweindall hätten s den gern zu sagen
das blaue
W Klass Witz sagte ja immer das
genau Robert Lempke ja in dem
Fall genau aber sozusagen die die
unheitere und die die die gleichgültige
Variante war ist mir wurcht welches
schweinler du mir jetzt anbietest der
interessiert mich nicht und das ist ja
nicht war ja auch die überflüssigste
frage ich meine wie egal war es welches
von diesen gleichaussehenden
meinesachens gleichaussehenden
porzellanschwein man richtig also wie
kann man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen
so eine Frage zu stellen das ist ja so
lepsch aber es war es die Wahl zwischen
drei genau gleichen Möglichkeiten oder
vier ich weiß gar nicht wie viel
Schweine da zur Auswahl standen wenn man
sich das mal anschaut die Klage die ich
vorhin auch zitiert habe oder die beiden
ja zu allen Zeiten haben Menschen
darüber geklagt dass so schlimm wie
Moment war sozusagen noch nie D muss man
doch eigentlich auch sagen wenn das so
ist und wenn wir jetzt auch gerade
offensichtlich oder möglicherweise
wieder in diese Falle tappen muss man
sagen möglicherweise sind wir dann auch
einfach ein bisschen weleidig und
vielleicht sollten wir das Jammern dann
einfach lassen und vielleicht sollten
wir einfach sagfindlicher befindlicher
abgehet wie frühere Generation und wir
erwarten mehr vom Leben ist richtig das
ist doch so also nicht nur dass wir
erwarten älter zu werden als andere
Generation sondern wir mürden wollen
wirklich extrem viel Freude Spaß und so
weiter in unserem Leben haben weil wir
eben die Haltung haben das Leben ist ein
Wunschkonzert und wir gehören den ersten
Generationen an und auch noch in den
richtigen Ländern bei denen davon
einiges erfüllt werden kann und das war
eben in früheren Zeiten nicht so
deswegen waren die Ansprüche geringer
mhm ja ja das ist war leichter heiter zu
sein früher weil man nicht so hohe
Ansprüche hatte ja und da muss man
eigentlich auch mal sagen also jedes
Leben hat so seine Erschütterungen und
jede Zeit hat auch ihre Erschütterungen
ja und das ist eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit und das hat es
immer so gegeben und deswegen sollten
wir aufhören rum zu rum zu raunzen ja
und
rumzupärenwe völlig meine Meinung also
hier Wehleidigkeit ist äh äh nicht
angesagt in dieser Situation das ist
genau wie mit Verbitterung ja Qualitäten
mit denen man keine Konflikte löst mit
dem man nicht weiterkommt im Leben weder
in seinem persönlichen Umfeld noch wird
die Politik dadurch besser mhm ich finde
auch ein bisschen weniger motzen ganz
gut ich meine wir haben ja auch häufig
kritische Dinge zu sagen ja aber so die
Relation zwischen konstruktiv und
destruktivm die finde ich stimmt in
diesem Land auch nicht ja es gibt in der
Tat unheimlich viele Dinge über die sich
aufregen kann über die man sich
beschweren kann und so weiter aber muss
ich immer wenn man sich darin aufhält in
dieser Welt fragen wie viel halte ich
mich in der anderen Welt auf indem ich
versuche Dinge besser zu machen mhm und
ich finde wenn das nicht einigermaßen im
Lot ist ja dann führt das auch dazu dass
einem die Heiterkeit flöten geht mhm mhm
das ist wahr was interessant ist ist ähm
es gibt ja
sozusagen finde ich Menschen und das hat
auch was glaube ich mit mit mit Sonne zu
tun ich will jetzt nicht zu viel
psychologisieren aber wenn du dir z.B so
die die Heiterkeit eines süditalieners
anschaust das ist schon anders als so
ein krüblerischer pemontesa ja wo das
Wetter tendenziell eher schlecht ist und
so weiter und ich muss immer denken an
an Karl weibbrecht der das war war ein
österreichischer Marineoffizier der ähm
1800 irgendwann 70er Jahren ist der
aufgebrochen in die in die russische
Arktis der der wollte eigentlich oder
die wollten eigentlich den Nordpol
erreichen und man hat ihm auf den Weg
mitgegebenesagt pass auf also wenn du
dahinfährst du musst Leute holen die
wissen wie man mit Kälte umgeht du
brauchst die Russen du brauchst die
Norweger ja du brauchst Schweden und so
weiter
du bitte keine Südländer und er hat
darauf klar man gedacht hat dass sie
nicht wetterfest sind genau ja einfach
Leute mit der Kälte nicht umgen Kön ja
ganz genau ist ja auch ist auch hat auch
was mit schlicht mit Erfahrung und mit
mit noh zu tun ja so wie jemand der mehr
lebt besser weiß wie man segelt ja ich
mir mir ist das mehr als jemand aus den
Bergen kommt ist total interessant ich
liebe das mehr aber es ist mir bis heute
unheimlich und wenn es dann sogar sogar
so ganz ganz tief blau und schwarz wird
das das macht was mit mir und nichts
Schönes während das anderen Leute ist
das völlig egal die Segeln dann da raus
und endlos weit und du siehst keine
Küste mehr denke Gott lass uns bitte
wieder zurückkommen mir macht das Angst
aber das war interessant der weibbrecht
hat hat Italiener mitgenommen und die
sind dann damals ja irgendwann von
Eismassen eingeschlossen worden ich ich
war auch mal an der Stelle dort ist
völlig irre Franzose fland das ist
höchste sibirische Arktis da da lebt
auch keiner aber sehr viele eisbeären
das war so ein Horchposten auch für die
für die Russen im im Kalten Krieg da
gibt es also so ja offiziell waren
Wetterstationen in Wahrheit hat man
Funksignale abgefangen und so weiter und
da kannst du bis heute vor sich hin
rottende und und rostende Fässer sehen
haben einfach alles zurückgelassen als
das große Imperium zusammenbrach und
sind wieder zurück nach Russland und
dieser arme weibbrecht ist dort
eingeschlossen worden und hat es dann am
Ende es war eine Meisterleistung also
erstens hat er dieses dieses diesen
Archipel entdeckt ja so eine so eine
Inselgruppe im Grunde östlich von
Spitzbergen
und hat das dann nach Franz Josef
benannt Franz josefland nach nach dem
österreichischen Kaiser und hat dann es
geschafft alle bis auf einen wieder
wohlbehalten zurück nach Hause zu
bringen se die Italiener haben dann auf
dem Eis da irgendwie botcha gespielt und
für gute Laune gesagt also es gibt diese
schöne diesen schönen Satz von ih sagt
ich ich bin so froh dass ich meine
Südländer mitgenommen habe weil sie über
das kostbarste verfügten worüber
Menschen in mitten der Drohungen des
höchsten Nordens überhaupt fügen können
und damit meint er Nacht ja die
Polarnacht und Eis und bittere Kälte -
40 50° sie verfügen nämlich über
Heiterkeit mm ist der entscheidende
Punkt ja großartige Geschichte ja und
ähm jedes Mal wenn man also dabei ist
irgendwo in seinem gefühlsmorass zu
versumpfen ja ab in die nächste Pizzeria
ja und sich an bestell ja sich sich
anstecken lassen von der Heiterkeit
übrigens als du das gerade erzähltest
mit den Sizilianern und den permontesen
und so inwiefern die Temperatur das
Temperament bestimmt also das Wetter
würde ich sagen in den 80er Jahren in
den 80er Jahren gab es doch so einen
Professor der war Experte für die
Vorsokratiker deswegen ist er aber nicht
berühmt geworden sondern weil er ein
populär philosophisches Buch geschrieben
hat also sprach Bella vistaano di
cresenzo und
die Verfilmung habe ich damals gesehen
so mit 2021 oder so und da wurde gesagt
der wichtigste Unterschied soweit ich
das in Erinnerung habe zwischen den Nord
und den Süditaliener den Mailändern und
den Sizilianern besteht darin dass die
Mailänder duschen und die Sizilianer
baden und das ist deswegen so der die
Mailänder Duschen weil sie keine Zeit
haben die arbeiten ja die ganze Zeit ne
während die anderen also in der
Badewanne sitzen und ihre Lieder
trellern ja ja und vielleicht ihr
Weinchen trinken und so weiter
vielleicht ist das sozusagen ich B ich
bin ja selber ich gehöre ja selber nee
und ja und Badewanne hat er gesagt ja
also ich gehöre ja der
badewannenfraktion an ja ich weiß es ist
jetzt ökologisch eine Sauerei ziemlich
ziemlich viel Wasser damit verbraucht ne
aber ich ich liebe das sehr gerade im
Winter ja ein ein ein Bad zu nehmen und
sich dann auch irgendwie ein Glas Wein
daneben zu stellen und so das ist doch
ein wahnsinnig schöner Ort für
Gemütsruhe und Heiterkeit das heißt du
liegst besoffen in der Wanne rum nee
nicht besoffen sondern ganz ganz
angeheitt ich habe von einem Glas
gesprochen
ja und ich habe auch von Wein gesprochen
und nicht von Schnaps oder von Rum oder
so ja nein aber das finde ich ist ist
großartig also badest gerne Richard also
die Entfaltung des sinnlichen trägt
massiv zur Heiterkeit bei ja und je
unsinnlicher eine Kultur umso
schwieriger und schlechter ist es mit
der Heiterkeit bestellt und deswegen
muss man Italiener mit zum Pol nehmen es
ist es wahr das war wie wie oft wartest
du noch mal ganz kurz wie oft machst du
das ab und zu einmal der Woche
ausgesprochen genau wissen also mit
Sicherheit und so weiter ja ich will
deine schmutzige Fantasie nicht weiter
anrichten auch nicht mit sauberem
Badeschaum so aber glaube mir dass ich
es nicht ungelegentlich gerne tue ja
wunderbar ich mach jetzt ein Geständnis
ich auch echt du musst auch zur
badefraktion ja total also selten ich
habe selten die Zeit dazu so sage ich
jetzt einfach
mal meistens eben nur stelles duschen
und so weiter Workoholic der du bist ja
ist doch herrlich ist ist doch wunderbar
also wo holst du denn jenseits der
Badewanne deine Heiterkeit her also was
ist der Quell deiner Heiterkeit weißt Du
tatsächlich also meine Mutter z.B ist
für mich ein großer Quell von Heiterkeit
die die hat bis heute so eine innere
Gelass he IT und einen Frieden der
irgendwie einmalig ist wenn man sie
fragt ich habe sie noch nicht gefragt
meine Mutter ist bald 90 ja und ich habe
sie neulich gefragt welches Alter sie
gerne noch mal erleben würde dann sagte
sie wie aus der Pistole geschossen
20 und ich sagte was war denn das
Lebensgefühl mit 20 und sie sagte na ja
also wir haben wahnsinnig viel
gearbeitet und wir hatten ja
nichts aber wir waren am Sonntag auf dem
Berg und in der Woche haben wir halt
hart gearbeitet
das war der Leben danach hat sie
Sehnsucht ja irgendwie ja und und es ist
heiter das ist glaube ich so das das das
Grundgefühl meine meine Mutter ist
wirklich ein heiterer Mensch auch ein
lustiger Mensch aber ein heiterer Mensch
die durch wenig zu erschüttern und
dadurch auch so unkorrumpierbar ne also
wenn du z meiner Mutter darüber redest
und sagst du du müsstest doch jetzt mal
mal das Meer sehen du müsstest doch mal
nach Venedig fahren oder sowas dann dann
sagt die nee warum was soll ich
da und das ist das ist diese heitere
Gelassenheit die ich so sehr liebe ne
jemand der der so so anspruchslos ist
und einfach so nein warum brauche ich
nicht es geht geht's doch alles gut der
ist natürlich wahrhaft frei innerlich
undhaft frei aber der ist Gift für
unsere
Wirtschaft wenn das jeder machen würde
wie deine Mutter ja dann wird unser
Wohlstand einbrechen ist wahr ist wahr
deswegen ja haben wir auch schon oft
drüber gesprochen ja der Kapitalismus
verträgt keine dauerhaft zufriedenden
Konsumenten das ist wahr ja also zu viel
Heiterkeit passt auch nicht zu ihm dafür
hat er viel zu protestantische Wurzeln
und die Protestanten waren noch deutlich
weniger heiter als die Katholiken das
müssen wir ja auch noch dazu sagen also
die sinnenfeindlichkeit und
heiterkeitsfeindlichkeit des
Protestantismus ist ja viel ausgeprägter
gewesen als in der in der Geschichte ja
irgendwann doch mal sehr Barock
angeschwollenen katholischen Kirche
deswegen ist es ja so dass der
Kapitalismus auch nur funktioniert
solange Menschen zyklisch unzufrieden
werden und diese Unzufriedenheit eben
durch neue kaufgelüste befriedigen
wollen also zu viel Gelassenheit passt
auch nicht zu unserem Wirtschaftssystem
das ist warah und ich habe zum Schluss
Richard was wahnsinnig schönes gelesen
von Karl Sagan das ist ein ja den kenne
ich US-amerikanischer Physiker genau
Astrophysiker Astrophysiker der einige
kleinere Bestseller geschrieben hat in
voren 80er Jahren genau der sehr früh
dann sehr tragisch glaub mit mit der 60
Jahren genau an einer Blutkrankheit
gestorben ist und ich ich habe
ich habe mir ein Buch von ihm besorgt
das eines seiner letzten Bücher wo er
sich so Gedanken über das Universum und
so weiter macht und und da findet sich
ein Gedanke den ich sensationell finde
da wird er gefragt wie er eigentlich und
das ist vielleicht der der der der gute
Weg jetzt rein in dieses neue Jahr um
alles ein bisschen gelassener und ein
bisschen heiterer zu sehen wie er auf
uns auf dem Planeten auf die Menschheit
schaut und er sagt wir sind im Grunde
Milben auf einer Pflaume und diese
Pflaume ist unser kleiner Planet der um
einen unbedeutenden kleinen Stern kreist
nämlich die Sonne und dieser Stern
befindet sich ganz weit draußen irgendwo
am Rand einer ganz gewöhnlichen Galaxie
der Milchstraße die ihrerseits
wahrscheinlich aus mindestens 400
Milliarden weiteren Sternen besteht aber
selbst diese Galaxie namens Milchstraße
ist nur eine Galaxie von mindestens 100
Milliarden anderen Galaxien die das
Universum bilden und das Universum
wiederum ist nur eines von hunderten
Milliarden Universen und vielleicht
sogar unendlich vielen anderen Universen
also die Idee dass wir bedeutend sind
und dass wir vielleicht sogar der Grund
für all das sein könnten ist erbärmlich
genau und damit hat er er gibt der
wieder womit nietche sein Text anfängt
über Wahrheit und Lüge im
außermoralischen Sinn da fängt er
nämlich umgekehrt an also mit dem in
myriadenstrahlen ausgegossenen Weltall
und so weiter wo es einen Stern gab auf
dem kluge Tiere das Denken
erfanden ja und das war die hochmütigste
und verlogenste Minute oder Sekunde der
Weltgeschichte ja der Stern erkaltete
die klugen Tiere mussten sterben und
dann war sozusagen wieder Feierabend
also von Anfang an sozusagen sagen
einordnen wie nie schreibt wie klein und
erbärmlich sich unser Verstand im
Universum ausnimmt und die schönste
Bearbeitung dieses Themas gibt es auf
Youtube da gibt es nämlich schon seit
über 10 Jahren gibt es ein Video das
heißt Dance Monkeys Dance genau Ken ich
ich weiß nicht ob du das kennst das
fängt mit dem Weltall an und das zoomt
so auf den Menschen runter ja und
beschreibt also unser primatenverhalten
ja also wir werden aus der aus der
primatenppektive von einem
Außerirdischen Verhaltensforscher
beschrieben bei dem was wir tun was wir
machen und so weiter das ist ganz kurz
ich weiß nicht wie lang ein zwe Minuten
und es bringt die Dinge so ultimativ auf
den Punkt es ist enorm beeindruckend
also ich find es ganz große klasse super
also Richard
Heiterkeit Axel Hacke endet ja genau
Axel Hacke endet ja hier noch die
Antwort auf die Frage wie man es
anstellt dann heiterer Mensch zu sein
die Antwort lautet vergiss genau diese
Frage mm schön
ja über also dadurch dass man darüber
nachdenkt glücklich zu werden wird man
nicht glücklich genau in diesem Sinne
Richard ich danke Dir sehr ich danke dir
auch und auf ein zumindestens das ein
oder andere Mal heiteres 2024 das
wünsche ich dir auch bis dann bis dann
tschüss
tschüss eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF